How are you? Cristian Cásseres greets you with
his brief News Now report in
Spanish. Classmates
paid tribute to the
high school student Ser Wey after he died from
consuming fentanyl pills. The
15-year-old's closest friends
wore shirts with his image and  school photo
four other students are reported to be in the process of
recovery after consuming the same
pills last wednesday the police are
not the dates indicate that no arrests have been
made in connection to
this incident
on the police people  metropolitan
that the brokers had their first
court date on armed robbery charges
our investigative team at news now
reports that rodgers is charged with an
armed robbery inside the
riu hotel gambling house in addition to
possibly two other robberies at  casinos
a bond of 250 thousand dollars was set
in case of paying this amount he will be
monitored and will not be able to go to the
las vegas hotel zone'
and tickets to see the publishers games
will go on sale starting
tuesday the home team will take on
the reno aces on tuesday april 5
within the dates because it is to
grind tickets for  75 home games
start at $13 visit
sears.com for more details
and we continue with rising
temperatures here is the
forecast where we can see
how temperatures will rise today and
continue for several days reaching
almost 80 degrees I don't know  forget that we are still
in winter and there are several weeks left for
the arrival of spring the cold will
return for the weekend I am
cristian casares with his brief
informative news now in Spanish good
day
[Music]